sajin decoy invested hundreds of
thousands of euros in this Italian
restaurant his biggest project yet with
a sports bar and nightclub to top it all
off his customers have a magnificent
view of Rwanda SCAP Atal Kigali but then
we get a letter for suspicion
differently from the district Gestapo so
you know you are a lot because you are
not sure if you're gonna make it
specially when you start a business
ideas you'd even know if this is gonna
work or not the 35 year old explains how
the authorities shut down the restaurant
shortly after it opened because of the
noise to remedy this situation he had to
dig deep into his pockets once again it
almost ruined him
there's a two windows inside we [ __ ]
when we started us on him one blood one
windows but that problem we agreed to so
you can see now it's taboo so at least
now we make sure like even people hear
this from music but it's not disturbing
neighborhood in dick ways other venture
is a dairy factory he started the
business eight years ago just like the
restaurant it also ran into problems
with the authorities they shut it down
saying it didn't meet hygiene
regulations
there were rumors his company was seen
as a threat to the state-run dairy
companies still the business has become
a success and its products are available
across Rwanda we got some reputation
it's literally not very smart not to
close because it took us eight years to
read this level I think if we give us
another little fold for Nia this photo
he can become a medium for touring the
businessman wants to expand and
modernize his production he currently
employs a dozen people but he plans to
double that number
this is the only way he can keep up with
the strict processing standards the
dairy processes more than a thousand
litres of milk each day putting out milk
yogurt and cheeses surgeon dick weighs
future projects include a country club
just outside Kigali he says he won't be
deterred by setbacks of course he hurt
but that in another hand I have a lot I
get a lot of support from the government
which push ourselves again to continue -
yeah - okay like an entrepreneur
entrepreneurs like surgeon take we are
helping create jobs for Rwandan and
transforming the once war-torn country
into a booming economy